Just a short time ago, the
governor, Josh Green,
told CNN that the death count
had risen to 99 people
and that in the coming days
that number could potentially double.
Also tonight,
there are now questions
about how well prepared
the island was for a major disaster.
State officials confirm
that none of the 80 outdoor
warning alarms
that are supposed to deliver
a loud, piercing
sound to residents in the tsunami
or were activated
and that The New York Times
called firefighters
who say the fire hydrant ran dry.
According to one firefighter,
there was just no water in the hydrants.
Tonight, we're also hearing more stories
of what it took to survive a fire
that, according to the governor,
traveled at an incredible
speed of one mile every minute.
19 year old Noah Tompkins
excuse me.
19 year old
Noah Tomkinson
and his younger
brother, Milo
and his mom raced to their car
as the fire spread.
They were caught in traffic
and they did
the one thing they thought
would save their lives
escaped into the ocean.
They were there for hours.
It was recorded on video.
Here are some of those moments,
beginning
with no speaking with his brother, Milo,
Oh, yeah.
You're going to be okay.
Milo. Milo.
Your mask is dirty.
It's better police.
I just wash.
Yeah, just wash it
Keeping your phone dry.
Yeah, right.
My phone's toast.
Yeah.
We'll run through the worst of it.
We're going to be okay.
I'm joined now by 19 year old
Noah Tomkinson and his dad, David
Noah.
When the fires hit your neighborhood,
you with your mom.
You're with your younger brother, Milo.
How quickly did you realize
you needed to get out of there?
Within it was about
five to 10 minutes from where we smelled
and saw the smoke over
over the hillside, over up on that
that big mountain.
Wow. That fast.
It was about that fast.
Yeah.
And you got into
you got into a vehicle I know,
but there was a lot of traffic. Was it?
How close was the fire
when you were actually in your car?
When we
when we were in our neighborhood,
it was starting to to
shoot embers down on the grass
and like the very dry grass on fire.
And at one point, we had left
when we were leaving our neighborhood
fires on both sides of our car.
So the decision to go into the ocean.
When did you make that decision?
It was
when we were coming down
the Front Street which which burned down
and the fire was at that point
starting to light the buildings
across from the street,
across the street on fire.
And we knew that we had to
and our car wasn't moving anywhere.
The traffic was so bad,
no one was moving.
So we knew we had to jump in.
You took video while you're in the water
and we're watching something
that I just want
to play
one part of the video
where you're talking about
the fire on all sides or
both sides
to the left and the right are on fire.
White folks are
starting to die
What was that like?
I mean,
to see what's happening on shore,
the smoke is clearly
I mean,
it seems like it's stinging your eyes
it looks like
it was difficult to breathe.
Can you talk about that experience
being in the water?
It was just so suffocating.
The water,
the air was so,
so thick, so heavy with with smoke.
And like I said in the video,
if you look to the left, it was on fire.
If you look to the right, it was on fire.
I think at that moment,
I was just realizing that we were going
to be in the water for a while.
How long were you guys in the water for?
About 5 hours on dry.
And you were
you were able to
to stand in the water, is that right?
Correct.
It was about for me, about five, ten.
It was about about chest deep
for for my mother and my brother.
They're both about five, four.
It was
it was much harder for them to stand.
You seem I mean, you're 19.
Your brother, Milo Anderson, is 13.
You seem to kind of know
what you were doing.
I mean, you
you you suggest to Milo
that he doesn't look at the fire.
I assume
that was because
of smoke, of sort of the.
The air coming and hurting his eyes.
Correct. It was.
It was for multiple reasons
until I told them both not to look.
It was.
It was because the wind was starting
to blow
and the smoke toward
that direction that dark, dark smoke
from the cars
that were starting to light up
and also the wind.
And
just in general, I didn't I didn't want
I didn't want him to see
what was happening behind him.
David, you
you live higher up in a different part
of Maui.
And I know you couldn't
get in touch with your kids
until the next morning. I mean,
I can't imagine what
that was like for you.
Yeah, it was about 12, 13 hours
where I had I had no I knew that the that
the fire had gone
through their neighborhood
by some videos that I saw online.
And at that point, I just I had no idea
I was not able
to communicate with them at all.
I just knew that they're
at a pretty good idea
of their house had burned out,
and I was just terrified for them.
I did
I did think that, you know, Worst-Case,
they're fit enough that they could,
you know,
run at least and get into the ocean.
And I but I had no idea
what was where they were.
And it was
it was terrifying
to just think
all these scenarios as I was
and knew
I had to try to get some sleep that night
and just felt guilty, me
laying in bed knowing that there.
Who knows where,
how we're going to finally be able
to get in touch with them.
So they they spent,
you know,
about 12 hours
start to finish
from when they had to escape
from when they finally got rescued.
And then later
they finally made it to us to a place
where they were able to get a cell phone
go up on top of the building,
and they were able to be high enough
to get a signal.
And Noah
calmly called me
as I was talking to my neighbor saying,
I don't know what's going on
or my kids are.
I haven't heard from them.
And while I was telling
while I was telling the story
to my neighbor,
Noah called me
and first thing calmly,
he says to me is, dad, we're okay
and we're okay.
And that was just a huge relief.
I at that point, I just knew
I knew everything's going to be okay. And
so, yeah,
at that point, I just I just,
you know, everything's going to be fine.
And whatever happens, they're safe
and it's all good.
Life's good at that point
because they're safe.
Now, I understand.
Even even though once
you got back on shore,
I think you found shelter in a vehicle or
you feel still you still were in danger.
I mean, I understand that smoke was
was just hanging over everything.
The smoke was just so heavy
and even even while we were in the car,
we still had our masks on
and we got a minute to sit.
And it okay, my
being in the car, of course, was better
being up
better than being out in the
in the smoke.
But it was just still so heavy,
it started to feel very suffocating.
No. What do you want to know?
What do you want people to know?
About what?
What people in the hunter need right now?
What the what the future looks like.
You know, it's a marathon, not a race.
So we need
we need those donations
spanned out along that time.
Then that would get to the most people
and help
the most people housing to housing this
temporary people are in shelters
and there's nowhere to go.
There's many families
that have taken on other people.
We have somebody in our home
who her house burned out in line as well.
And you know, our business burned down.
The owner of the business,
his house burned down,
his neighbors, everything.
You know, it's
so many people
are without homes right now.
I mean, you must be so proud of
no one in my life.
I mean, your son
Noah has quite a head on his shoulders.
I mean, to be as calm
and credibly thoughtful in those moments
is extraordinary.
Yeah, I'm very, very proud of him.
I just from the moment he told me that,
it was like
right away,
I felt so proud that he was able to
I knew I just those words, the way
he said
them, said so much to me
about how the whole situation was handled
and that he really was there
to support system
for his brother and his mother.
And they needed each other to survive.
And I'm so thankful for for them
to also be
that they were together
and that Noah was so calm
in this whole thing.
Very, very calm.
It's I'm very, very proud.
Yeah.
Both My brother
will Noah,
if I ever get in trouble, I'm calling you
because you seem to have a good head
on your shoulders,
and I know what you're doing.
I mean, I know it.
David, I appreciate both of you.
Thank you so much.
And I wish them continued strength
years ahead.
Williams, thanks.
So you can find a lot of information
about how to help at
CNN.com forward slash impact
or you can text Hawai'i to 70, 70, 70
to donate.